- MY PLAN WAS TO TAKE PHOTOS
OF THE EVENT
AND THEN POST THEM ONLINE
SO SALOMON WOULD SEE HE MISSED
OUT ON A REALLY FUN PARTY.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE FEW DESIRED
GUESTS I INVITED SAID
THEY COULDN'T MAKE IT
ON SUCH SHORT NOTICE.
BUT I STILL FELT
VERONIQUE AND I
WERE ENOUGH TO HAVE A PARTY.
DO YOU...SPEAK FRENCH,
OR IS IT
JUST THE ACCENT YOU DO?
- NO, I SPEAK FRENCH.
- OH, OKAY.
- AND I DON'T WANT TO BE RUDE
BUT I REALLY HAVE TO LEAVE
SOON SO...
- WITH VERONIQUE
ON THE VERGE OF LEAVING,
I WAS HOPEFUL THE ENTERTAINMENT
I HIRED
WOULD TURN THINGS AROUND--
A PROFESSIONAL BILL GATES
IMPERSONATOR
WHO I'D WORKED WITH IN THE PAST.
- IT'S REALLY GREAT TO BE HERE.
THERE'S NOTHING LIKE A PARTY.
YOU KNOW, UH...
YOU WORK HARD ALL YOUR LIFE,
ESPECIALLY TRYING TO GET
MICROSOFT WORKING.
I MEAN, MICROSOFT.
WHAT WOULD WE HAVE DONE
WITHOUT IT?
IN THE OFFICE DAYS--OLDER OFFICE
DAYS, IN THE '80s
YOU HAD BIG COMPUTERS
IN A ROOM.
I MEAN, ENORMOUS.
AND LOOK AT THE TECHNOLOGY NOW.
IT TAKES A INVENTIVE MIND
TO RUN AND INVENT...
THIS MICROSOFT.
AND I'M VERY HAPPY.
[awkward applause]
- AFTER BILL'S PERFORMANCE
THE PARTY HAD REACHED ITS PEAK,
SO THE ONLY THING LEFT TO DO WAS
TAKE SOME PHOTOS OF THE EVENT
BEFORE VERONIQUE HAD TO GO.
AND AFTER AN HOUR OF GETTING TO
KNOW THE MAN BEHIND BILL GATES--
WHY WERE YOU CIRCUMCISED TWICE?
- WELL, THE FIRST TIME, UM...
THERE WAS A PROBLEM
WITH THE FORESKIN.
- I WRAPPED THINGS UP
AND THE NEXT DAY, I POSTED
MY PARTY PICS ON FACEBOOK,
WHERE I WAS SURE SOLOMON
WOULD SEE THEM.
WITH EVERYTHING IN PLACE,
IT WAS NOW TIME TO TEST
THE IMPACT OF MY IDEA.
SO I BROUGHT VERONIQUE
INTO THE OFFICE